so I received a mysterious package in
the mail today and it turns out it was
the limited-edition collectors version
of the homeworld remastered collection
from gearbox I haven't opened it yet so
we're gonna open it together and already
I'm excited look at this this is
beautiful
I don't want to like carry all my things
in this box it's magnetized alright so
right on top we have Oh
the revised historical briefings and
artwork for homeworld and it looks like
this is a glossary of terms and people
and things and some information on how
to use your armor on your ship and other
gameplay related things and farther back
it looks like we have some original
artwork for homeworld
there's a couple I saw a line-drawing as
I flipped through earlier this is like
really pretty here we go that's really
nice so book we get a book and directly
under that beneath this flimsy piece of
tissue paper I have my code for
homeworld which I'm not going to show
you because you might take it sorry guys
and we're here I'm still worried I'm
gonna break this cardboard this is like
super nice cardboard you hear it squeak
and everything so it's a keychain it
looks like it's a keychain I can't get
it out right now it's a keychain with
the official homeworld insignia that's
super cool now there's a lot of heft to
this box and this is really shallow so I
wonder what is under here styrofoam I
wonder what's under this styrofoam hold
on hold on this is awesome it's fit so
it smells really interesting it smells
almost like lemongrass in this box and
in it is a replica of the mothership
from homeworld and a base for it
mothership replica assembly in usage I
was right assembly in usage recommended
for ages fourteen plus choking
hazard so maybe don't give this to your
younger homeworld fans out there
and it comes with the bass and the bass
looks like the stone that they show at
the beginning of the game and the
introductory cutscene and that's about
it and it all fits really nice and
snugly in here so whole world remastered
edition collector's edition you get a
replica of the mothership to put on your
bedside table so it's the first thing
you look at every morning when you wake
up and be thankful that we got a
remastered edition of homeworld you get
a awesome keychain to show off to all
your friends a art book and a copy of
the game itself
you